لطالما كانت الصين تهديدًا
لتايوان
لمدة أربع سنوات
، وقد أصبح الأمر أكثر خطورة في
السنوات القليلة الماضية وكان دائمًا على
هذا النحو
سواء كان المتحدث بيلوسي يزور تايوان أم
لا ، كان التهديد العسكري الصيني ضد
تايوان موجودًا دائمًا وهذه
هي الحقيقة التي نحتاجها  للتعامل مع هل
كان النظام الديمقراطي في تايوان في أي وقت مضى في
خطر أكثر مما هو عليه اليوم
يمكنني أن أخبرك أن تايوان أكثر
مرونة من ذي قبل
انظر إلى تايوان هذه الأيام التي تعرف أن
الصين تحاول فرض عقوبات تجارية على أه
ضد تايوان تحاول مهاجمة تايوان
من الجيش  أو الجانب غير العسكري ،
تستمر الحياة هنا في
تايوان وتظهر تايوان مرونتها إذا كان
الناس في تايوان أكثر قلقًا مما
هم عليه بشأن الصين
جيدًا ما يمكنني قوله هو أن الناس
هنا في تايوان قد يقلقون
إذا سألتني
قليلاً ما الذي تقلق بشأنه ، فأنا
قلق من أن الصين قد تشن بالفعل حربًا
ضد تايوان ، لكن ما
تفعله الآن هو محاولة
إخافتنا بأفضل طريقة للتعامل معها
لتظهر للصين أننا لسنا خائفين